The following is a meditation for the fourth
fundamental motivation of existential analysis, helping us answer
the question of, for what should I live
my life?
We offer an experience of the possibility of
what it could be like to live with
meaning in your life.
The speaker and creator is Graham Nelson-Zetter.
Please take a moment to find a seated
position where your back is supported, you feel
comfortable, and you have the ability to place
your feet on the ground.
You may find that sitting in lotus feels
comfortable for you.
Just ask yourself if it's possible for this
position to be more comfortable.
Perhaps if seated in lotus, you may even
place bolsters or pillows under your legs.
And if seated in a chair or couch,
just adjusting your posture, giving yourself the opportunity
to have some alignment between your spinal column
and your head, noticing if you're leaning forward,
backwards, or to a side, just seeing if
there's a possibility to have more vertical alignment,
and inviting you, if you're not able to
do so, to find pillows or some form
of neck support for your neck and head
to ensure that there's no strain.
And once you find yourself in this position,
I invite you to gently rest your hands
on your lap, maybe check and see your
temperature, noticing if there are any adjustments that
can be made.
Once you're seated comfortably, to take a moment
and feel support from underneath, noticing that the
support in the floor and the support in
the chair and couch are connected to a
larger network of support.
The floor that you're on is connected to
a structure of a building, which is connected
to a foundation, and this foundation is resting
in the earth.
Just as this building rests on its foundations
in the earth, you too sit here in
this chair, on this floor, sharing in the
support, inviting the groundedness of the earth to
come up through the foundations of this building,
the structure of this building, to the floor,
to your feet, and to your lower legs,
upper legs, glutes, and sitting bones.
Asking yourself if it's possible to invite more
of this grounded energy into your body.
The idea of electrical grounding or energy grounding
might become helpful here, thinking of how excess
energy that might be present in your body
has the opportunity now to go through your
feet to find some balance, and this excess
of energy is able to leave and dissipate
through your body gently without any effort, and
as that charge leaves your body, just checking
to see if you're willing to accept this
grounded energy in its place, inviting this balance
within the body, and
shifting your attention to your breath without the
need to change how you're breathing, just noticing
that you've been breathing this whole time.
There's no need to control how you're breathing,
and it can be helpful to notice that
you are inviting this oxygen-rich air into
the openness of your lungs as they expand,
and as you exhale, allowing this carbon dioxide
to release, to relax out of your body,
both the in-breath and out-breath, not
requiring any additional effort, holding the awareness that
your body will continue to breathe whether you
focus on the breath or not.
You may recall that the oxygen you breathe
is part of the oxygen that all of
the beautiful plants of this earth create.
As the
as the photon hits the carbon dioxide molecule,
the very same carbon dioxide you exhale, the
light splits the CO2 into carbon and oxygen,
the plant keeping the carbon for its growth
and releasing the oxygen back into the air
for you to breathe the very same oxygen
that you're breathing now with every inhale.
You may notice places where your skin is
exposed to the air, just noticing what it's
like to be in contact with the air,
and you're also wearing a mask.
You may notice places where your skin is
covered with clothing, sticking in this difference in
temperature, perhaps noticing texture or light pressure of
your clothing, becoming aware again that you have
this flexible boundary between you and the world.
Wherever you go, your skin and your clothing
go with you.
Again, nothing is required for you to do
here.
This natural, flexible boundary is here to protect
you, whether you focus on it or not.
Your breathing will continue to nourish your body
with rich oxygen from these plants, whether you
focus on it or not, and the earth
will continue to support you, holding you from
below, whether you focus on it or not.
In our previous journey together, we had the
delightful experience of encountering our special tree, and
I invite you at this time to meander
down the paths that lead you from your
home to this park or meadow, making your
way back to your beautiful tree.
And as you come upon the tree, noticing
again its shape, its width and height, the
shape and color of its canopy, noticing its
branches, its bows and its trunk, and noticing
whether it has leaves or needles and the
color of these leaves and needles.
And as you continue to walk gently towards
your tree, something new is visible to you.
Your tree has started to change in a
really interesting way.
As you look at the branches of your
tree, you notice that they seem laden, bending
downwards in a way that they hadn't been
before.
And as you get closer and closer to
the branches, you notice that this tree has
produced fruit.
Now, the nature of the fruit of your
tree will be specific to your tree, and
I invite you to allow this fruit to
emerge in just the way that it chooses.
The fruit of your tree may be known
to you.
It may be a type of fruit that
you are aware of.
It may also show up as something new
and unique that you've never seen before.
I invite you to allow the fruiting of
this tree to be exactly as it is,
showing up with curiosity about the nature of
this fruit.
For some, the fruit may be fleshy and
may have a large seed within.
For others, the fruit may be fleshy and
have many small seeds within.
For others, the fruit may be hard like
a nut.
And for others, the fruit may appear more
like a cone of some kind with texture.
Just take a moment to really notice the
color, the shape, the texture, the
weight of your tree's fruit.
And as you look at the ripe fruit
on the branches of your tree, you notice
that some of this fruit has already fallen.
And as you turn your gaze downwards towards
your feet, you notice that below the branches
of your tree, some of its fruit has
already fallen to the earth, resting gently in
grasses or moss.
You find a fully intact fruit.
This fruit has no bruises and is ripe
and ready.
And you reach down and pick up the
fruit left to you, offered to you by
your tree.
As you hold your fruit, noticing its weight,
how hard or soft it is, bringing it
up to your nose and smelling it, noticing
if it has smells that are more sugary
or sweet or pungent or perhaps more woody
and nutty or something entirely new and different.
Just taking the time to allow your senses
to notice what this fruit is like.
And luckily, you've brought a bag with you.
And you take a moment to gently place
this fruit inside your bag, looking upward to
your tree, letting the tree know that you
intend to enjoy and take care of this
fruit.
Perhaps offering some thanks for the unexpected, beautiful
gift and letting your tree know that you'll
be heading home and that you look forward
to the next time that you encounter each
other.
And then gently churning away towards the path
that leads out of the meadow and the
park towards your home.
As you make your way home, you feel
the bag, thinking about the fruit within it.
And you're suddenly aware that not only is
this fruit, it's also a seed.
On your way home, as you ponder this
unexpected gift, you contemplate the idea, the possibility
that this seed holds the power and ability
to become a whole new tree under the
right conditions, with the right support, with the
right care, with the right protection, with the
right amount of water and attention.
This seed could become a little version of
your tree.
And it dawns on you that at your
home, you have some potting soil.
You recall that in your home, there's a
really nice place in front of a window
where you could plant and nurse a baby
tree.
As you get home, you find your soil,
you find a little cup with holes or
a little nursing pot, and you prepare the
location for this seed to begin this process
of transforming into a baby tree.
If your fruit has flesh, then you gently
remove this flesh from your tree.
You may notice that this flesh is either
edible or not edible.
Trusting your instincts around this choice and deciding
whether the smell and flavor of this fruit
is one that you choose to consume or
don't, and you collect the seeds or pit
from this fruit, making sure it's nice, clean,
and ready to be planted.
Somehow you know just how deep in the
soil your seed should be.
For some seeds, they need to be a
few inches down.
For others, only a centimeter or two.
And for other seeds, they prefer to rest
atop the soil.
Somehow you know exactly the right way to
plant your seed.
And you give just the right amount of
water to your seed, wetting the soil on
this first day.
And you feel this sense of hopefulness and
contentment, this unexpected possibility of new life, this
desire to care for another living being.
And noticing how the relationship with you and
your tree has the possibility of becoming something
new.
It's possible that you may be caring for
the child of this beautiful tree that you
found in the park.
And content with this opportunity, you go about
your day, eventually going to sleep.
The following day, you wake, checking in on
your seed, noticing that the soil could use
some water.
You go ahead and water the soil, noticing
as you put this effort into supporting the
possibility of this new growth, there is this
building sense of excitement and anticipation.
Something cool might happen.
And if you continue your efforts, you may
just discover that your seed has sprouted.
And you go about your day doing the
things you do.
And you come home, going back to sleep,
waking again, watering your seed again, checking to
see if it sprouted.
Not yet, but maybe soon.
And you go about your day doing the
things you do.
And you return home and go to bed
again.
And the following morning, you get up and
you check on your seed again, watering the
soil again, noticing not yet.
It hasn't sprouted.
Hoping that it will soon.
And you go about your day again and
come home and eventually go back to sleep
and wake again.
And this cycle continues each day with you
tending to the seed, making sure it's nice
and moist, that there's enough water for it
to wake from its slumber.
And you wake again, going to check in
on your seed.
And much to your delight and surprise, you
discover a little green shoot sticking out of
the soil.
What a delight.
All of your efforts have gone towards this
critical moment, this beautiful moment where you can
tell that the seed has awoken and a
baby tree is now sprouting.
Soon after this moment, you find yourself walking
around and you have this urge to go
and see your big tree in the park
that you've been going to.
And there's this feeling of excitement and anticipation.
You're going to let this tree know that
its seed has produced offspring and there's a
little baby tree in your house.
And off you go to your park and
you go see your big tree and you
let your tree know the good news.
And there's this shift, subtle shift in the
relationship between you and this wonderful tree.
There's a sense of connection and responsibility and
possibility that wasn't there before.
The connection was lovely and yet there's something
new and special here.
This possibility of life in the future, something
growing into something bigger.
And there's a sense of glow between you
and this big tree, the parent tree in
the park.
And having had a moment of appreciation and
connection and hopefulness with this big tree, you
decide to take the path, eventually returning to
your home.
And you go to bed and you wake
up the next morning and discover that this
beautiful little sprout is even taller than it
was the day before.
And with care and excitement and encouragement, you
offer this sprouting baby tree more water.
And you go about your day with this
special glow, knowing that you're involved fundamentally in
supporting the growth of life itself.
And this big, beautiful tree that's been so
kind to you, that's offered you a place
of relaxation, a place of support and protection,
you're able to do something nice in reciprocity
with this tree.
Your care, your attention and your appreciation for
the fruit and seed from this tree has
resulted in this beautiful baby tree growing bit
by bit in your home.
And every day you check in on this
baby tree, noticing its progress.
And every night you go to sleep with
this feeling of having contributed to the life
of another living creature, knowing that this is
also the offspring, the child of that big,
beautiful tree, your favorite tree in the park.
And day by day, week by week, this
baby tree gets bigger and bigger to the
point where you notice that it's outgrown its
pot.
It's time for a new pot.
And with care and gentleness, you prepare the
new pot with more potting soil and you
help loosen the roots of the baby.
And you transplant this beautiful baby tree into
its new pot.
And position the new pot, again, close to
the window where this growing baby tree gets
lots of light.
Just the right amount of light for what
it prefers, offering more water and welcoming it
into its new pot.
And as the days go on and the
weeks go on, this baby tree grows and
grows to the point where it doesn't really
feel like it's a baby anymore.
And yet again, you notice that it's outgrown
the pot that it's in.
And you find the lovely new pot for
it and even more potting soil.
And you prepare the soil to transplant this
baby tree, or now adolescent tree, yet again,
loosening its roots, placing it in the new
pot with new soil, and offering it water
to help it grow.
Again, positioning it near the window with just
the right amount of light for it to
thrive.
And as the days go on, and as
the weeks go on, you discover again that
this little one has grown and grown and
now is ready for a new pot yet
again.
And you prepare this new pot with care,
with fresh soil, and you transplant this adolescent
tree into its new pot again, loosening its
roots, allowing it to settle into its new
pot with fresh water.
Again, placed by the window with just the
right amount of sunlight for this adolescent plant
to thrive.
And the days go by, and the weeks
go by, and the months go by.
And before you know it, this adolescent tree
is as tall as you.
It has definitely outgrown its pot yet again.
And it's now time to consider whether it
could go outside.
And although you love having this beautiful tree
in your home, this tree is getting big
and strong and is ready to be out
there in the world, participating in nature.
And as you consider this, although there's some
sadness that this tree won't be inside your
home every day to enjoy, there's this possibility
of a perfect location.
As you think about where this tree could
live outside, this beautiful spot comes to mind.
And as you think it over, you go,
and you say to yourself, yeah, I think
I have just the right spot.
And you go back to the park where
the big parent tree is.
And with much delight and anticipation, you have
this moment where you acknowledge the fruit that
fell from this tree not that long ago,
that had a seed within it, that you
cared for, that you took home, that you
planted, that you watered, that you transplanted, that
you cared for, is now ready to be
out in nature, noticing the cycle of life
continuing and the opportunity for this tree to
be enjoyed by others.
And you let the big parent tree know
that you have just a spot in mind.
And although this tree doesn't seem to use
words with you, you have this sense of
reciprocity from this tree and even a sense
of thanks and appreciation from the tree to
you for doing such a good job of
caring for its young.
And off you go back home, and you
prepare your adolescent tree that's already taller than
you at this point to be transplanted to
its new home.
And off you go to that very special
place together.
Perhaps you have a cart with you, or
something that can help you carry this much
larger tree than the little baby one that
you first sprouted at home.
And you make your way to the location
that this tree is going to grow and
thrive.
And you dig the hole, and you dig
it deeper, and you get it to just
the right depth for this tree to grow
into.
And you have all the soil you need,
and you go ahead and you transplant this
tree from its pot into the earth.
And for the life, it has the pleasure
of being planted directly in the earth.
And you water it, and you make sure
it's doing well.
You add any topsoil that it needs, making
sure that it's nice and stable.
And you say a little goodbye to this
tree that you raised in your home that's
now ready for the outside world and to
be part of nature.
As you walk away, you give a little
wave to your tree, heading home, thinking about
how happy it's going to be now that
it's able to reach out and begin to
grow into its full potential in nature.
This tree is big enough and strong enough
now that it can make it on its
own.
It can even find its own water.
And the next day, you go back to
check on it.
And sure enough, it's doing wonderfully in its
new spot.
And you go about your day, go to
sleep.
And the next day, you come back and
check again.
And it's doing wonderfully in its new spot.
You picked just the right spot for it.
You put your hand in the soil and
notice that it's still nice and moist, and
the tree doesn't need any watering.
It's doing great on its own.
And every day for the next few weeks,
you come by to check and see how
your tree is doing.
And it's doing wonderfully.
And before you know it, the seasons are
changing.
And it's possible that if you have the
type of tree that changes with the season,
that your tree begins to go through some
of these seasonal changes.
You may also have the kind of tree
that doesn't go through these seasonal changes and
stays just the way it is.
And as the weather begins to change to
cooler temperatures, your tree does just great.
You feel like you don't have to check
on it quite as frequently as before.
You pop by at least once a week,
sometimes more, sometimes less.
And every time you pop by, you notice
your tree has gotten bigger and bigger.
And as the weeks go by and the
months go by, spring returns, and you find
that your tree continues to thrive.
And as the seasons go by, your tree
continues to adapt and grow and thrive and
adapt and grow and thrive and adapt and
grow and thrive.
And as the months and years go on,
you continue to age, noticing the natural transition
of your body.
And you go and check in on your
baby tree that is no longer a baby,
and notice that it has matured into a
sturdy, beautiful tree.
It has so many of the characteristics, colors,
shape, and textures of its parent tree in
that beautiful park.
And there's a sense of appreciation that you
have been part of life perpetuating.
You've been an essential ingredient in the success
of this life.
And as you come back and check on
this tree, from time to time, you notice
that other people are enjoying it too.
Sometimes children play under this tree.
Sometimes teenagers and adults lean against this tree,
reading books, listening to music, meditating, or having
naps.
And as your life goes on and you
continue to age, you realize that this tree
is still growing.
And it dawns on you one day that
this tree is very likely to outlive you.
And although your life may come to its
natural human end, something really beautiful has been
left here.
The care, comfort, and support that offer this
tree have allowed it to become something really
special.
Your continued efforts to help raise this tree
and to find a place for it to
thrive.
All of these efforts, all of this activity,
have helped this tree grow from a tiny
little sprout into this big, beautiful tree you
see before you.
So similar in stature and strength and beauty
to its parent.
You have been able to enjoy the process
of witnessing this life thrive.
And you've created, co-created, this opportunity for
others to enjoy such a beautiful tree.
And maybe in the future, the tree that
you planted will finally get to maturity, where
it too produces fruit.
And at some point in the future, someone
like you may stand there admiring this beautiful
tree that you planted and notice that this
tree has also borne fruit and left it
gently on the ground.
And this person too may take this fruit
home, discovering its seed, helping this little one
churn into a new tree.
As the tree you planted continues to grow,
a bunch of wonderful creatures have decided to
make it a home.
Some parts of the year, birds make their
nests in this tree, providing them with a
space to raise their young.
And deep down in the roots, this tree
connects to the mycelial network, touching other roots,
sharing resources, connecting to a larger network of
nature.
One day, someone plants a tree nearby, and
deep down in the roots, the tree that
you planted and this new tree connect.
Your tree notices that this other tree is
young and could use some support and offers
it to share its carbon and its water
and resources, helping this younger one grow into
a big, strong tree as well.
And as the years go on, more and
more animals make homes in these trees.
And more and more people have the opportunity
to enjoy spending time under this tree, this
tree that you planted so many years ago.
I encourage you to take a few moments
to return to your body, return to this
room, into the shared space where you are
in together, be finding your breath, noticing the
floor under your feet.
And in your own time, I invite you
to gently open your eyes and come back
into the shared space.